TUCKER, GREAT SHOW.
THANK YOU.
BUSY NEWS NIGHT.
WE ARE TRACKING HUGE MULTIPLE
BREAKING STORIES.
WE START TONIGHT WITH THE
MASSIVE DEVELOPMENT OUT OF THE
MUELLER WITCH HUNT.
TONIGHT MORE EVIDENCE EMERGED
THAT BOB MUELLER'S REPORT WAS
NOTHING BUT PURE POLITICAL
GARBAGE WITH ERRORS PUT THERE ON
PURPOSE.
JOHN, SOME OF THE KEYS OF
MUELLER'S ASSERTIONS ARE FALSE.
THE MUELLER REPORT DESCRIBES
PAUL MANAFORT'S BUSINESS PARTNER
AS A SHADY INDIVIDUAL WITH TIES
TO RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE.
MUELLER WANTED US TO BELIEVE
THAT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS IN
BED WITH THE RUSSIAN SPIES.
TONIGHT WE KNOW THAT'S TOTAL BS.
CALLING IT MUELLER FAKES.
MANAFORT'S BUSINESS PARTNER WAS
A SENSITIVE INTELLIGENCE SOURCE
FOR THE U.S. STATE DEPARTMENT.
THAT'S A BIG DIFFERENCE.
WHY DID MUELLER DECEIVE WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE?
HE VISITED THE U.S. TWICE IN
2016 TO MEET WITH STATE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS AND FOR
YEARS HE MET WITH THE CHIEF
POLITICAL OFFICER INSIDE THE
U.S. EMBASSY IN KIEV.
MUELLER HAD ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION.
SO HE AND HIS MERRY BAND OF
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS AND TRUMP
HATERS THAT, MEANS THEY LIED IN
THE REPORT.
AND MUELLER CAST A DARK SHADOW
THIS INDIVIDUAL'S REQUEST TO
PRESENT A PEACE PLAN TO THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN IN 2016.
THE VERY SAME PLAN WAS PRESENTED
TO THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION THE
SAME YEAR AND MUELLER'S TEAM
KNEW IT.
MUELLER, WHY WOULD HE DO THAT.
SOLOMAN IS NOT THE FIRST
REPORTER TO RAISE CONCERNS AND
WON'TING THE LAST.
THIS IS OUT RIGHT LYING FROM
MUELLER AND HIS DEMOCRATIC DONOR
FRIENDS HE APPOINTED.
A DISTURBING PATTERN OF LIES AND
CHARACTER ASSASSINATION.
ON MONDAY WE FIRST REPORTED THAT
MUELLER EDITING A TRANSCRIPT
FROM A FORMER TRUMP ATTORNEY
JOHN DOWD WHO WAS ON THIS
PROGRAM AND CALLED THAT REPORT A
FRAUD.
DURING A PRIVILEGED CALL BETWEEN
ATTORNEYS, MUELLER OMITTED
DOWD'S STATEMENT AND HIS REQUEST
FOR COMMUNICATION WAS NOT ONLY
FOR THE PRESIDENT BUT FOR THE
COUNTRY AND HE WAS NOT ASKING
FOR ANY CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION.
THAT EVIDENCE WAS RIPPED OUT.
THAT'S A CLASSIC TACTIC.
SIDNEY POWELL'S BOOK "LICENSE TO
LIE."
WISEMAN WITH HELD EVIDENCE IN
THE PAST.
WHY WAS HE APPOINTED?
THAT'S NOT ALL.
AND MUELLER'S 9 MINUTE LONG
DIATRIBE LAST WEEK.
THE MEDIA WAS FULL OF HOPE AND
ANTICIPATION THAT THEY FINALLY
GOT THE PRESIDENT.
THAT ENDED UP BEING DEBUNKED A
FEW HOURS LATER.
IN FACT, THE DOJ POLICY
INDICTING A CITY THE PRESIDENT
WAS NEVER A CONSIDERATION.
HIS PRESS CONFERENCE WAS A
CONTRADICTION OF EVERYTHING HE
SAID.
IN A JOINT STATEMENT HOURS
LATER, THE DOJ, BARR AND THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL OFFICE WAS
FORCED TO WALK BACK AND CLARIFY
THE 9.5 MINUTES THAT MUELLER BUT
COMMENTING AND REAFFIRMED THAT
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S REPORT
MADE CLEAR THE OFFICE CONCLUDED
IT WOULD NOT REACH A
DETERMINATION ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER ABOUT WHETHER THE
PRESIDENT COMMITTED A CRIME.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT POLICY WITH
WHETHER YOU CAN OR CAN NOT
INDICT A PRESIDENT.
EVERYTHING MUELLER SAID WAS FAKE
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR BAILED
HIM OUT.
HE WAS BEGGING NADLER NOT TO
TESTIFY OR BE SUBPOENAED BECAUSE
HE KNOWS HE HAS TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS FROM JIM JORDAN, AND
MARK MEDICINE AND DEVIN NUNES
WHO WILL JOIN US IN A FEW
MINUTES.
WELL, MR. MUELLER, WHEN DID YOU
KNOW THERE WAS NO COLLUSION?
WHY DIDN'T YOU END THIS WITCH
HUNT?
WHY DID YOU ONLY HIRE HARD-CORE
DEMOCRATIC DONORS INCLUDING A
FORMER HILLARY CLINTON ATTORNEY
FOR THE CLINTON FOUNDATION.
WHY HIRE WEISSMAN WHO LOST IN
THE SUPREME COURT 9-0 AND HAD 4
MARYLAND OFFICIALS PUT IN JAIL
AND THAT WAS OVERTURNED.
WHY APPOINT WEISSMAN KNOWN FOR
ATROCIOUS CONDUCT.
ATTENDED HILLARY CLINTON'S
VICTORY PARTY ON ELECTION NIGHT.
IT DIDN'T WORK OUT WELL.
THE PATTERN IS CLEAR.
WHAT WE SEE NOW TIME AND TIME
AGAIN, THE SPECIAL COUNSEL M
MANIPULATES INFORMATION ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
WHY DIDN'T HE HAVE TIME FOR THE
DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER THAT
HILLARY CLINTON PAID FOR THAT
WAS USED TO INFLUENCE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE?
NO EXCUSE FOR THAT.
NO COLLUSION, NO OBSTRUCTION ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN'S PART.
THE TRUMP HATERS REVERTED TO
PLAN-B.
THEY CREATED A DOCUMENT INTENDED
TO FUEL EVEN MORE LIES AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES FROM
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR ALLIES IN
THE BIASSED AND CORRUPT MEDIA
MOB.
IT WAS A POLITICAL HIT JOB FROM
THE BEGINNING THROUGH AND
THROUGH.